-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And everybody watching at home.
Thank you.
Well, guys, the weekend
kicks off
the unofficial start of summer.
That's right,
happy Memorial Day.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Happy Memorial Day
to all of you,
except for that guy
in your office
who sent a work e-mail
at 4:59 p.m.
You go, "No, we're not reading
it, Carl."
I have a feeling people
are going to really
let loose this weekend.
Don't you have that feeling?
[ Cheers ]
By this time tomorrow,
the cornhole boards
will just be two guys passed out
with their mouths open.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
According to AAA,
nearly 40 million people
are expected to travel 50 miles
or more this weekend.
When asked where they're
going, everyone said, "Anywhere.
Literally. Anywhere else."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, with so
many people traveling
this weekend, gas prices
are expected to skyrocket.
Yeah, the bad news is gas
is expensive.
But good news is you'll have
something to talk about
with your father-in-law.
[ Laughter ]
"Can you believe
how expensive the gas --"
Gas is so expensive,
when I filled up this morning,
a guy in a tux was like,
"Might I recommend
the Sunoco 92?"
[ Laughter ]
"Excellent choice,
Mr. Fallon."
Speaking of traveling,
a new survey finds
that the majority of Americans
won't take a road trip
without the perfect playlist.
And 35% said they'd turn the car
around if they didn't have one.
[ Laughter ]
What's more troubling is only 8%
said they'd turn the car around
if they forgot
one of their kids.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-"Ah, he doesn't listen
to my music anyway."
Yeah, you spend days
making the perfect playlist,
then you spend the whole trip
trying to connect
your phone
to the car's Bluetooth.
It's really fun.
[ Laughter ]
"Alright, everyone turn
their Bluetooth off!
Everyone turn --
Now I got to pull over.
Here we go.
Then we're gonna have fun.
Everyone turn it off!"
Get this -- according to
the National Hot Dog
and Sausage Council...
[ Laughter ]
...73% of Americans believe
that a barbecue
is not complete
without hot dogs.
I think the bigger story here
is that we have
a National Hot Dog
and Sausage Council.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Send me a T-shirt, man.
-Number one.
-A lot of Americans are going
to barbecues this weekend.
And sometimes you have
good barbecues.
Sometimes you have bad ones.
So we actually came up
with some clues, some warnings,
to help you guys realize
that you're at a bad one.
So if you see this --
For example, if you're at --
you're at a bad barbecue
if your neighbor's
wearing an apron that says,
"French kiss the chef."
[ Audience ohs ]
That's disgust-- that's gross.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Here we go, this warning here.
A 911 call includes
the words "grandpa,"
"lawn dart," and "impale."
[ Laughter ]
That means you're
at a bad barbecue.
-That's a bad one?
-This is a bad one, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Here's another warning --
bad one.
The neighbor's teenage son
sneaking shots of lighter fluid.
-Okay.
-Don't have him burp
by the grill. Yeah.
Also, here's another warning.
Good news -- there's beer pong.
Bad news -- it's with
Natty Light Sour Seltzer.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
-That was a mixed reaction.
Someone out there likes it.
[ Laughter ]
Someone likes that.
-Is that real?
-I'm not afraid of it.
I'll try it.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, warning,
a guy with seven fingers says,
"Who wants to shoot off
some fireworks?"
Just some warning signs.
Just a couple.
If you see those, just know.
Well, changing gears, today
Senate Republicans
voted to block
the January 6th commission
that would investigate
the Capitol riots.
[ Audience booing ]
After the vote, Republicans
said they'll gladly explain
their decision in an upcoming
QAnon -- I mean Q&A.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
That's a great crowd.
Senate Republicans said they'd
rather investigate
something more important, like
why wasn't Paul Rudd
in the "Friends" reunion?
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That makes more sense.
Here's some good news.
Right here this weekend
all New York beaches
will be open,
and vaccine buses
will be stationed
on a few of them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And just to make sure
they attract a crowd,
all the vaccine buses
will play the Mr. Softee jingle.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the vaccine buses
are a great idea
because when they're done,
they can just toss the needles
on the beach
with all the others.
[ Audience oohs ]
"Hey, what are you gonna do?"
[ Laughter ]
"We're at the beach!"
-"Hey, I'm with
the Sausage Council!"
-"That's right. We work
for the Sausage Council.
What he said."
[ Laughter ]
Another sign that
we're returning to normal --
Costco is bringing back
their free samples.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't worry, though.
They're still being careful.
Now a Costco employee
will just slingshot
a cheese cube into your mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
American Airlines
just announced that they're
partnering with Rosetta Stone
to offer language courses
to passengers during flights.
-Ooh.
-You think someone kicking
your seat is tough,
imagine sitting next to some guy
sounding out French
for six hours.
[ Laughter ]
"Bonj-- bonjoi-- Bonjoar?
Aurevware? Aurvware. Aurvwar.
Aurvwar. Aurvwar.
Aurvwar. Bonjar.
Bonjar. Aurvoir. Jonbar."
John Bar Jarvoir, everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Love him.
That's right.
The airline's also offering
courses like photography.
So flying isn't awkward enough.
Just wait till a stranger's
snapping photos of you sleeping.
[ Laughter ]
"You looked
beautiful and peaceful."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this made me laugh.
Yesterday a CNN reporter
was preparing for a live shot
when he realized
a cicada was on him.
Take a look at this.
-Am I going to be in the --
in the same block out of this
or going to take a break?
Okay.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh!
Oh, my God!
[Bleep]
[Bleep] cicada.
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone in the control room
was like --
they just sat back there like,
"Let's just see how this --"
[ Laughter ]
"Let's see how this plays out.
Let's not say anything."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of cicadas,
a photographer in Virginia
has recently picked up
an interesting new hobby.
Check this out.
-We started with
my son's fire truck.
I decided to do
a cicada rock band.
This cicada is doing archery.
[ Laughter ]
This cicada was lifting.
Look, Ping-Pong.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so clearly not everyone
made it through quarantine okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Ping-Pong.
-Guys, finally, as I mentioned,
Monday is Memorial Day,
and people are excited
to go to barbecues again.
I love a good
old-fashioned potluck,
where everyone brings a side.
But there's nothing worse
than when no one
wants to eat your side.
Here, let me explain with
a "Tonight Show" tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ It's my first barbecue
in two years ♪
♪ Can't wait to see my friends
and crack some beers ♪
♪ Dave brought fruit salad,
Ann brought rum lemonade ♪
♪ But no one's touched the thing
that I made ♪
♪ Somebody eat my carrot slaw ♪
♪ Please somebody eat
my carrot slaw ♪
♪ Heard someone ask, "Hey,
what's that supposed to be?" ♪
♪ Glad my grandma's not
'cause it's her recipe ♪
♪ Somebody eat my carrot slaw ♪
♪ No one put it on their plate
even though I'm right here ♪
♪ Saying, "Doesn't
this look great? ♪
♪ Now I'm leaving the party ♪
♪ Can't look people in the eye ♪
♪ So I'll just throw it
in my freezer ♪
♪ Till the fourth of July ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two, three, four.
♪♪
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Uh, we have to do it again.
We have to do it again.
-We got to do it again?
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. That's what I call
sausage council.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I wanted to give a quick
shout-out
to our friend Lady Gaga.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because we love her,
and this week is the 10th
anniversary of her album
"Born This Way."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she's been a great friend
of the show.
It's her first number-one album.
This record is just so important
to so many people.
And we just wanted
to give her some love.
[ Cheers and applause ]